[Music]
great news this just a few hours old
today the u.s. women's soccer team won
the gold medal yeah I just want to say
all of us in America are happy for the
athletes and thrilled we don't have to
watch soccer for four more years
[Applause]
certain people just do that as for
anything yeah yeah sure good cookie USA
as of now this is interesting the US is
leading China in both number of gold
medals and number of total medals yeah
in in response China said that's nice
but we still have all your money
everybody laughed and then got sad
you're like this is being reported that
Olympic swimmer Ryan Lochte might be the
next Bachelor but he's the perfect
choice he'll give the winner a rose and
then pee in her pool nice part of the
ceremony this is what's being reported
that Adele Adele may perform at the
Olympic closing ceremony yeah it should
be pretty emotional and stirring because
a few years ago the Olympics broke up
with her there's some sad some but not
everyone is happy with the Olympics
though Olympic corporate sponsors are
upset because the athletes are using
unauthorized brands of condoms yes
that's true they're using are not Tories
run of condoms and these corporations
are upset get the angry sponsor is
McDonald's who issued two kinds regular
and Mik ribbed for her pleasure
pretty happy with myself Mars rover I
like the money we got some Mars rover
fans here I'm sure it's a robot it can't
hear you that's so sweet
Mars rover starting to send back
pictures after studying photos taken by
NASA by the NASA space rover scientists
are saying that Mars resembles
California yeah think of it both have
little water large mountains and the
possibility of hidden aliens
[Applause]
because of immigration I see what he did
yet crazy story
check this out kids a man shut up a man
my own people are laughing at me a man
who ordered a television off of Amazon
was shocked because Amazon instead sent
him a rifle yeah which means somewhere a
hunter is trying to kill a deer by
making it watch The Real Housewives of
New Jersey
[Applause]
[Music]
trying to change the channel doesn't
have a control divers I didn't mind that
divers off the coast of Italy have
discovered a 2000 year old shipwreck
that is so well preserved even the food
is intact
is that amazing the food 2,000 years old
here the food was carefully extracted
from the rack and immediately served at
the nearest Olive Garden taste is a we
just lost a sponsor one of my favorite
things that's played producers least
favorite dance we just lost the sponsor
you shouldn't do it not after we need
the money